and again not a month goes by without
Disney announcing another live-action
movie in the last few years it was
mainly new editions of 90s Disney
classics such as Beauty and the Beast
Aladdin for the Lion King is life action
film adaptions as the well informed
website The Insider now reports Disney
is currently working on a film adaption
of Hans Christian Andersen's fairy tale
The Snow Queen which already served as a
loose template for Disney's mega hit
froz according to current information
however it is not supposed to be an
official remake instead the project with
the English title The Snow Queen will
revolve around a completely new story
whoever was looking forward to a reunion
with Anna and Elsa will be disappointed
at this point therefore you can strongly
assume that the new project will be even
more oriented towards Andersen's fairy
tales than it was ever the Kanes with
frozen if you can still remember the
development process of the first frozen
part you will find that the story around
Elsa and the early stages was much
closer to Anderson's original and that
Elsa was originally planned as the evil
Snow Queen in the entity of delight of
many fans the bitterly Evil Snow Queen
became the Elsa we know so in the new
The Snow Queen we can assume that we
will get to see the character from which
Elsa was created as a villain or
antagonist after all in the original
movie the evil Snow Queen kidnaps the
orphan boy K and forces his companion
Gerda to rescue him which role the magic
mirror created by the devil place in
this case you can either read in the
fairy tale collection of Hans Christian
Andersen or you wait for the release of
The Snow Queen an exact date is not yet
known but according to current formation
the movie will not be released in Disney
Plus but in the cinema after Mad Max
fury road was a great success especially
with critics it was clear to director
George Miller that he would work on
several follow-up projects however
before its Mad Max turned in the leading
role again there will be prequel about
the fan-favorite furiosa s miller
announced a few days ago choice Theron
who very credibly impersonate a
character furio's and Mad Max fury road
will not return to the camera for the
prequel the reason is obvious for
prequel around the story of furiosa you
need a younger actress Aniyah taylor joy
and Jodi Kumar are supposed to be in the
casting for this role so far
also explained that he had also
considered having jollies Theron
digitally rejuvenated as was the case
most recently with a Martin Scorsese
Mafia film the Irishman but Miller told
the New York Times that he had finally
rejected the plans but who will at least
definitely return as cameraman John
Seale and set designer Colin Gibson with
their work both have played a decisive
role in making look of fury road so
unique
Gibson even won the Oscar for his work
afterwards because of the much younger
leading actress we suspect that furiosa
will play some years before fury wrote
so the focus will most likely be on her
youth and her time and the so-called
Greenland in the movie she also reports
that she hasn't seen her home country
for at least 7,000 days which is about
20 years and thus can be seen as a rough
distance between the prequel and Mad Max
fury wrote it might still take some time
until the movie's release as director
Miller has to finish his fantasy epic
3,000 years of lightning first therefore
a release of furiosa before 2023 seems
pretty unlikely as Variety reports this
week actress Hal Barry has been
confirmed for the female lead role in
Roland Emmerich's latest disaster movie
called moon fall Barry has most recently
appeared in successful films such as
John wick 3 or King's Men the Golden
Circle and now she's supposed to play
alongside Josh GAD in moon fall the
actress slips into the role of a former
astronaut who's now rather working
behind the scenes in the administration
thanks for a long experience in space
however she soon realizes that one of
her former missions can help prevent the
impending catastrophe the worst case
scenarios that the Moon is thrown out of
its orbit by a mysterious force and dust
crashes down to earth so a group around
the former astronaut has only a few
weeks to prevent a terrible disaster
without further ado with the team
travels to the moon and meets an unknown
but very powerful force there the script
for the film was written by the trio
role Emmerich Herald closer and Spencer
Coleman were already involved in the
script of the Apocalypse film 2012 so we
can hope that moon fall will be as
thrilling as 2012
the shooting of Emmerich's film will
start in autumn but unfortunately
there's no official release date yet as
we reported last week Boba Fett returns
to the Star Wars universe in the second
season of the Mandalorian
many other characters have joined him
including Timothy Olyphant which role he
will play was not known until now but it
now turns out that Oliphant will wear
the famous green suit of Boba Fett in
season two of course this does not
automatically mean that all ofin will
also play Boba Fett's and stay more and
more escena still plan to play him
according to slash film.com Oliphant
will instead play the human cub then but
why is he wearing the Mandalorian armor
there could be a hint in the aftermath
trilogy because their cub also stole the
green armor from Efrain kuru but how we
get old Boba Fett's armor remains
unclear for now the character was
originally developed for the extended
universe in this universe cub is a slave
who after the death of Jabba the Hutt
takes care of the safety of his town as
Sheriff however the extended universe
officially no longer belongs to the
Canon therefore it remains to be seen
whether the office of the Mandalorian
will decide to use the background story
of the character for the TV series what
do you think which other character can
you imagine in the Wild West setting of
the series in the last few days an
unusually high number of rumors about
the release of the Snyder cut which has
been demanded for years could be
witnessed it is the original cut of
Justice League that director Zack Snyder
made before his tragic departure from
the project it was never released
because his successor just wheaton
rejected the original version so what
was released in 2017 didn't much have to
do with Snyder's vision and didn't meet
with much enthusiasm from the fans since
then there have been rumors of release
every now and then but it never became
reality at least until three days ago
when the director himself announced the
Snyder count at a man of steel watch
party this finally brings to life what
we have already discussed in many news
episodes and especially the fanbase is
allowed to Pat itself on the back for
its commitment in the form of a hashtag
released the Snyder cut because without
the great participation of the net
community in the Twitter campaign the
film would probably still not exist
according to the Twitter channel of HBO
max the film will be released on the
streaming platform as early as next year
[Music]